[Musique]
rue du faubourg montmartre près des
grands boulevards petite gueule
gaston guiraud nous étions plusieurs
camarades qui prenions nos repas dans un
de ces grands restaurants populaires
appelé bouillon à prix fixe pour 60
centimes on y déjeuner en entrant dans
l'établissement on remettait à la casse
hier le montant du repas en échange
duquel nous recevions le nombre de
jetons correspondant aux plats qui
allait nous être servis et c'était un
plat de viande zéro franc va un légume
0.10 un fromage un dessert et un morceau
de pâte du même prix on voyait les plus
riches boire admis ce type de vin rouge
mais cela était de conditions supérieure
à la nôtre
[Musique]